[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et bien c'est très simple je vous le dis
je vais choisir trois personnes qui vont
danser pour moi les trois meilleurs
danseurs de l'émission c'est mathieu
d'honneur et la médaille peut vous
mettre la mer sur mathieu vous êtes à
kelly vedova nuit et le troisième
meilleur danseur de l'émission c'est
tout pour moi à l'école c'est mon doc
gynéco alors attention mettez vous
retournez vous les chéris non non de son
côté rester comme ça c'est bien grâce à
rester comme ça qu'il faudrait c'est
comme ça attention les chéris vous allez
devoir me dire un deux ou trois et vous
allez avoir un partenaire de non ça peut
être un très bon partenaire ça peut être
un duo dans ne regardez pas qu'il
remercie je peux être à dio ça peut être
quelqu'un seul ça peut être une place où
ça peut être un truc bien on va demander
moi je peux commencer mon honneur non
faune hamdaoui
merci et perrine damas que doc gynéco a
choisi ses 1 2 ou 3 3 3 ne danserai que
l'a3 à moi quelle est la 1 et vous vous
danserez ton un mec bien ken tous les
deux de jouer la 2 attendu les deux
raids
alors je vous le dis derrière là
derrière une des cabines il y un très
grand danseur de danse avec les stars
derrière une autre cabine il y a mais
deux grands-mères s'y fait et derrière
une autre cabine
i il y à bébert le frelon et ma maladie
est marié à la veille à votre grande là
qu'il met de grands mères ya deux grands
verres à boire et bien le frelon oui
donc j'ai les crocs où il avait choisi
la cabine numéro 3 attention on verra ça
tout à l'heure va démarrer par la cabine
numéro une
c'est vous qui avez choisi la cabine uv
rhône je vais demander à mathieu et doc
gynéco des maires sur quelle chanson
vous voulez danser c'est les
téléspectateurs qui vont voter pour ce
concours de danse sur quoi voulez danser
un rap d'accord donc grèce la foire et
ouais j'suis en bout la chermoula
toujours va rappeler c'est ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
kelly
vous allez devoir tout les bouchons au
cours de danse attention kelly vous avez
choisi la cabine numéro une vous allez
danser avec
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis déjà été franchies contre lequel
on va vous donner le top
attention exaucer vos grands-mères sont
bons il qu'un elles sont très belles
kelly vous donner tout ce qu à chaque
fois vous donner 4 11 points 4 sur sa
tombe le dire et baba je vous lis des
autres merci attention kelly c'est parti
donnez tout on y va
[Musique]
je sais tout je sais pas dire je
m'affranchis contre le quai où il fait
alors mettez bongo alors les chéris
météo l'a fait au moins un solo non
matin et c'est quoi ce on dirait qu'on
est dans une banque on va mon frère vont
se mettre autour de vous et attention
qui n'a les moyens solo un bon moyen
selon ses parents
[Musique]
je la vois
ah ah
je sais tu irais je sais pas dire je
t'aime
merci comment vous appelez communiqué
choisi par les et vous êtes magnifiques
qu'on choisit arles et merci d'avoir été
là
soixante dix huit ans et 80 connectez
vous avec votre partenaire faut pas
retenir son attention par et autant les
deuxièmes danseurs deuxième danseurs
c'est bien sûr matthieu delormeau
c'est un grand homme et un grand
retournez vous vous allez danser c'est
ou à très grands danseurs de danse avec
l'histoire ou bien ces deux danseurs un
peu moins bon mais qui sont sympathiques
ou alors de ré mais ce qui est un peu
comme exactement deux mois alors allons
soir dans ça matthieu delormeau vous
avez bien choisi la cabine numéro 2
watts en musique aussi vous soutirer la
musique juste après avec d'abord on va
voir avec qui vous allez danser matthieu
delormeau matthieu delormeau vous allez
danser avec la soupe leur bébert le
frelon est malade allez c'est pas à
nathan quelle musique c'était 5000 alors
qu'à musique tu veux je connais pas une
mop alors il faut dire le videur est
agrippé passé pour toi c'est comment la
ville bouge bien mais j'espère et ckoi
beach gbagbo ni pro gbagbo ni vas-y
hockey ahl et donne tout mais vous me
suivez
[Musique]
ah ah
allez mon bébé
[Musique]
là
mais m
m
[Musique]
c'est nul
est ce que tu veux faire un solo ce que
je sens que tu es pas un danseur de
trion montre-moi le matthieu delormeau
que je connais mal à y aller en arrière
à plus de micro j'éprouve une micro pour
annoncer ma fille tu vas prendra pas à
faire mon chemin professionnel je vais
le rester c'est danser et baisers il ya
des empreintes heureusement des mousses
femme est mort le frelon comme ça pas de
sortir son d'arthur varika vraiment que
ça allait aller chercher mettez vous sur
le côté on va les laisser est ce que tu
veux comme musique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
à
c'est
[Musique]
pour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
r
c'est chaud
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
face au dollar mais ça c'est moche au
plo ça
[Applaudissements]
oh
ah là là là les mecs là on a vu un
champion mettez vous la mettez vous
lasser et meetic mais alors très bien
allez-y
allez-y mettez-vous la retire pour moi
dans la tension elle donne gynéco
normalement tout se passe bien c'est
avec un très grand danseur très haut
edoc a eu de la chance puisqu'il est
avec
ouais mais dans le spectacle de chris
marquès oui ils auront c'est un
spectacle exceptionnel
alors on danse et nouveau show événement
et je suis très heureux que tu sois une
soirée un mot ça me fait plaisir c'est
que fout de toi
et ben moi aussi thiebaut ont tous
intégré alors suis trop content me faire
avec doc d'unicopa ce que mon père et
les méga fan de toi là bas au delà nous
regarde a pris dans la nasse adore aller
vous voulez danser sur la musique qui me
plaît c'est toi qui bouge énormément
alors taquine à qui on va écouter battre
mais aussi calme à on peut leur mettre
pour qu'ils sachent que c'est le montre
la d'abord passer le témoin était pas
dans ses bras son frère à prendre les
gens comme ça faut que tu puisses tu
danses vraiment faire ce qui nous reste
à sanoma later bitches
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les pièces
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
franchement c'était gai mais il me
semble si il somme c'est un vrai dans ce
château
c'est quand même fou away et c'est pas
facile je vais prendre n'importe qui
donc la porte et qui allez rire je
prends d'abord de guide en plus bien
être choisis ont dansé avec quoi vous
arrive vous vous allez chaude à l'essai
[Applaudissements]
ah oui
dayal aulas il est alors temps je te
remets bientôt micromonas attention mais
la musique que je je pense là bas on va
reprendre inspire n'est pas sympa pour
licata vous à lui [ __ ] la honda stuff
qu'est-ce qui danse bien calme à kalma
wasquehal massenya savez je dis pareil
comme ça et on a bien travaillé
belle attaque
m
[Musique]
dallas
pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
est-ce que vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]